before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
take two Doctor Who reviews are back
time to continue the re-watch
where did I leave off
[Music]
oh
yeah I I've been putting off continuing
my revisit to the Christian Jody
Whitaker era of Doctor Who
because I got to flux and flux is oh boy
flux is a very
specific kind of disaster
it's oh boy
so this is gonna be odd for me to talk
about because this is by far the
freshest of the stuff I mean that's
natural as I work my way forward but
like it doesn't feel all that long ago
that Flex happened but I do want to get
through this re-watch ahead of the
premiere of the new stuff uh and also
I'm taking the opportunity to uh
actually at the same time as I'm going
through this watch trial of a time lord
for for the first time and kind of see
what happened when classic era doctor
who tried to do a sort of overarching
story
um the results are pretty much there uh
as well but right now we're talking
about this
so
this is what we're gonna talk about
first and I will get to trial of a Time
Lord I haven't
decided yet if I'll put those out here
on the main Channel or in the break room
most classic goes in the break room I
don't know I I'll figure that out but in
any case we have to start with
the Halloween apocalypse
I will be very curious to see what kind
of response I get to this video because
I remember the response I got when I was
very skeptical when this episode aired I
basically declared it to be an
overpacked mess of a start and I got a
fair bit of crap for that actually at
the time got a fair bit of crap for each
of the episodes that I said this isn't
really working which is
most of them and yeah that does include
the one that everyone else seems to
think is good we'll get to that though
but
I remember the reaction at the time was
you know you can't be so hard on it this
is just the first part it's a serialized
story yeah they've got a lot of stuff to
set up and I'm gonna repeat now what i s
what I was trying to say at the time
which is that that alone cannot excuse
this because regardless of the fact that
the story is meant to continue and this
is not a self-contained complete story I
accept that but even as a chapter one
this is a mess this is an overstuffed
disaster the story itself the
overarching story of flex is severely
overstuffed but the fact that everything
is crammed into this nearly every
element is introduced here even though
there's nothing for it to do here or a
lot of it isn't going to pay off till
the very end some of it in ways that
makes you wonder why was that even there
in the first freaking place this is
absolutely
stuffed with stuff and stuffed with
stuff God what a turn of phrase that
ends up being but it it is over packed
there is way too much going on here and
no matter what excuse you want to make
oh but it's only a first part like yeah
but it was presented on its own it was
presented as here's your first taste
don't you want more and when it's this
over packed with things that I can't
figure out what the heck is supposed to
be the main draw who a lot of these new
characters are why I'm supposed to care
about them why we are seeing about half
the stuff that we've been seeing at all
and you're trying to dangle it all in
front of me don't you want more I'm like
I don't even know what you gave me so no
I don't know if I want more
it's it's like when people tell me well
you can't judge a movie just by the
trailer like yes I can that's why the
trailer exists to be judged they want me
to judge that I see the trailer go yes I
want to see the movie you can't tell me
that the first episode of a serialized
story I can't judge it I can't judge the
entirety but I can judge this it was
presented to me as something for me to
consume and judge and I will I'm a
little bit bitter about that argument
I've actually gone off on it years ago
people do not tell me not to judge
things by the not to judge trailers but
like that's why they exist
same with first chapters
anyways
when I say this is a mess is there
nothing good here
well no as is true of the entire Jody
Whitaker and Chris terminal era there's
stuff to like there's some stuff that
I'm like oh actually that kind of works
or boy I kind of wish there was more of
that because it's not focusing up
properly but what is good
honestly
Dan's good which was surprising at the
time because I bemoaned his casting
initially because my big hope going into
this after
um both uh Graham and Ryan both left was
that it would just be as in the doctor
and would focus in on that relationship
I didn't actually want it to be a ship
I'm not a shipper and I generally don't
root for that but I did want that to
become like the definitive doctor
command relationship and I wanted it
explored and expanded on and really put
a focus on and I honestly felt and still
kind of feel that adding another
companion in the form of Dan distracts
from the ability to do that and I stand
by that that's kind of what happened but
Dan has a character himself he's not the
problem
I would still might argue he really
shouldn't be there at all but if he's
going to be there he's charming and his
introduction is one of the few bits of
Fairly succinct storytelling that is
giving just the bits you need but giving
you just barely enough breathing room to
feel like okay I get a sense of this guy
because we find out how proud he is of
his hometown we get a sense of his
relationships with a few people we get a
sense that he very much wants to help
people but that he himself seems to be
incapable of asking help or even
accepting help when it is offered to him
and this is just over the course of a
few scenes and we get a pretty decent
sense of him as a character and it's
buoyed by the performance as well he is
a well-introduced character who probably
shouldn't be there but he is so I need
to get off that issue he is here he's
decently introduced
he's another one now that's buoyed
primarily by the design which is
adorable and sort of this put upon
gruffness that the performer brings
nothing what do you think of that well
that's what's happening so
side because his basic attitude is like
I would really rather just leave this
human to die but I'm obligated so I'm
here and I'm doing it just shut up and
let me do my job and I just kind of like
that attitude I find it entertaining A
lot of times as long as you don't over
push the cynical end of it I think they
balance him just right because he may
talk about how he doesn't care or he
looks down at people whatever but you
can tell from his actions or even just
his line delivery like he does care he
doesn't like that he cares but he does
care and I actually really like that
that doesn't fully square with a lot of
the other stuff going on with him like
how many fatal traps he leaves behind
and how they're trying to put this
emphasis on uh how much he cares about
Humanity at the same time he seems to
care so little about other stuff there's
this whole idea introduced of like this
this species bond between the lupari and
the humans which
is an idea I kind of would have liked to
have seen expanded upon because it seems
to just be banking on the notion of you
know dogs man's best friend and like
that's a fair enough point to start but
you know you could have
actually explored that a little bit we
can't there isn't enough time but I do
like calvinista the doctor in Yaz are
fine they actually don't get a lot to do
they're too busy running around actually
to the point that Yaz is
so we come in and we get a cold open
that is already them
in a life or death situation and it's
very it's just it's just bad it's bad it
like you know they're not actually gonna
die and also like they managed to
survive being dropped into I guess it
was acid by grabbing onto the thing and
like there's these drones right there
that are going to shoot them and they're
just hanging they're just hanging on
this thing they're not moving and the
drones that are like five feet away
can't hit them it's it's really dumb
it's really dumb and it's really bad
it's highly unnecessary you could have
just had them tracking down calvinista
without this at all and it really begs
some questions because it's not until a
little bit later that Yaz is going why
are we even doing this like you just got
out of a life and death situation and
now now and like it was implied that
that situation they'd already been
tracking him for a bit now you're
starting to ask questions and it just it
just
undercuts the idea of the two of them
bonding in their relationship which was
something I really wanted to the show to
get into more again not necessarily
romantically but it just not only does
it not do it on screen it kind of
implies that they're not even bonding
that well between stories which is the
least you could have freaking done so
while their performances are not bad
they are saddled with basically almost
nothing to work with which is honestly I
think kind of my big issue overall
looking back at Jody Zara when she's
given something to properly sink her
teeth into
she's great
but a lot of the times the writing gives
her nothing but technobabble and you
know exposition to to spew out when
she's given actual character stuff she's
really good it's not even that she's bad
at the exposition but there's only so
much so much character you can inject
into Exposition and technobabble and she
does what she can with it but that's
that's there isn't enough to dig in
there and so I I really just I really
just wish he had better Scripts
so there's that and then there's
then there's the over stuff now I've
talked before in another video rather
extensively about some of the problems
that this series had going in such as
the fact that by every indication that I
can find the number of episodes they
were going to get to do this was cut
down and it was done at a time when they
didn't have a ton of well they Christian
and his couple of co-writers did not
have the time to completely rework the
story so that it fit in a smaller format
and instead just had to basically there
was indication that there was one
episode that was completely excised but
everything that was left just being
crammed into a tighter space and you can
tell
you can tell because this is trying so
hard to set up almost every element that
is going to be in flux basically the
only thing that I can uh think of off
the top of my head that it doesn't set
up are Bell and the Great Serpent but
they're both connected to something that
is getting set up in this which is
vendor but vendor doesn't do anything
other than witness the start of the flux
which we don't really know what it is we
don't know why the lupari know what it
is and we don't know why the doctor
doesn't know what it is we have the
whole setup with the villain so swarm
and as an Azure
um
they're real generic the thing is they
they come in with this big I've returned
doctor energy and it doesn't work there
is one of two ways that that could have
been made to work one would have been to
actually have it be recurring baddies my
vote would have been either for Omega or
the gods who were trapped in uh can you
hear me either one of those I think
would have worked and actually had some
weight of somebody returning or failing
that
you can if you have good performances
and admittedly admittedly the
performances on these villains are good
but again the writing is not there
but
the other way this could have worked is
if we get this strong sense of a
personal history with the doctor and
these villains that the we as the
audience haven't seen the show's been
doing this since classic like curse of
fenrick did this and there's there's
plenty of times that it comes up this
idea that the doctor has a history with
these villains but the audience just
hasn't seen it before
but they don't even do that because the
doctor doesn't remember them
which means that their entire oh doctor
I'm back and I'm projecting the fact
that I escaped into your mind like it
had it literally serves no meaning
except to
just try and justify the exposition dump
because they forgot to uh to actually
have the master project thoughts into
the doctor's brain back at the end of
the previous series they said that he
did but he didn't I went off on that
before moving on
so we've just got this generic skull
Facey looking dude let's I say generic
the design is actually kind of
interesting like the the kind of
crystals and the sparkly effects but
sort of reminiscent of a skull like it's
not a bad design and like I said the
performances are decent there's pretty
good
um Charisma especially from swarm but
you carry no weight dude you're just one
more thing that has shown up out of
nowhere and claims to be all-powerful
okay we get a lot of you and also like
as yours be
her being trapped in the body of a human
makes no sense
because like swarm has been trapped it's
implied for
thousands millions who knows how many
years
has she been like reincarnating as
humans over and over like how did that
even work and why why would you imprison
one of them one way and the other that
way why would anyone do that
no answer no acknowledgment that it's
even kind of off or weird it's just
okay he breaks loose and then
turns this woman into his sister who I
guess she always was but didn't know but
the fact that that's the case and that's
how she was trapped does nothing to
inform anything that is going on or
anything that will happen so why
why is that here
we've got the stuff with the tunnels
under uh Liverpool I think it it's where
the tunnel whatever like the tunnels
aren't going to matter until the very
end and honestly even then the story
didn't need them they could have made
use of something else and they certainly
didn't need to be set up this early when
you're wondering what the hell is going
on we have what the hell's her name
Claire she shows up talking to the
doctor like she knows what's going on
but then later running into the Weeping
Angels but acting like she's surprised
to see them so does she know what's
going on or doesn't she and to what
extent is it what like what is it which
is that's going on and we will kind of
get an explanation on that later but it
doesn't justify her being introduced
here as yet one more element where why
why introduce these elements this early
when they're not going to pay off in
this case for another three episodes
what is the point of dropping it this
soon when we're not gonna remember do it
closer to when it will matter there's
the fact that Azure and swarm kidnap
snapped die the the woman that
um Dan was going to meet up with for
drinks and
off the top of my head I can't remember
if they ever explained why they went
after her specifically
like why they would do that why would
they care
and like if it's because Dan's connected
to the doctor he wasn't yet how do you
know that like I can't remember if that
gets explained or not off the top of my
head I'm gonna go on a limb and say it's
not but like it might be and I might
have forgotten but at this point in time
at this point in the story The question
is why like because you know Azure and
swarm are talking are giving these
implications of wanting to destroy the
universe why do you care about this one
woman
that why why does this specific woman
matter it makes no like the thing is
what it's trying to do is be like look
at all these questions you're gonna find
answers to the thing is though
it's over stuffing it with questions
because you can have multiple questions
but you need and something like this you
need a firm basis around which to have
those questions orbit and you can't ask
all of them at the same time because it
makes it so we don't know which of these
questions matters more we don't know if
the important question is why are the
lupari
um species bound to humans we don't know
if the important question is why did
they kidnap that we don't know if the
important question is why did the
Weeping Angels show up we don't know if
the important question is why is the
TARDIS leaking fluid we don't know which
of these is important because you've
just dumped all of them
there was no reason for all of them to
be brought up now and like way more
besides the ones I've even mentioned we
have the introduction of the centaurans
already which I mean like fair and so
far as they're gonna show up in the very
next episode so like that one I guess
I'll let go but like the episode ends
with like a montage of characters that
we don't understand why they are here we
don't understand why they matter
what is the main thing that we are meant
to hold on to as these questions circle
around us
I don't know and I because I think what
the story wants it to be is the threat
of the flux the problem is we don't know
what the flux is exactly what like
destruction okay that's too vague and
you clarify that too late and the doctor
doesn't even know what it is yet so we
don't know if it's something we should
be taking seriously because she doesn't
fully know what it is yet so that
doesn't work because there's too many
questions surrounding that too
if you want an example of how you start
off with something where you can have a
ton of questions but a firm concrete
starting point look at the first season
of Lost
now whatever you think about what
happened to that show eventually but
that first season that first episode
especially has some weird stuff go on
some real weird stuff lots of questions
but you know what
Firm Foundation plane crash on island
how do we survive
that is a clear concise foundation
around which all the weirdness and the
questions can Circle there's no Central
pillar in this nothing of the Myriad of
things that are introduced and shoved in
our face and presented with no
explanation is given to us in a way
that's like okay that's the thing that
we latch onto and we focus first and
foremost it's all just the circling
questions with nothing to stabilize it
and just as a quick point of clarity for
anyone who is going to try and insist
that the threat of the flux is the main
Central pillar and the thing that
stabilizes the story I'm going to argue
that it's not because the only degree to
which we understand it is that it is
threatening everything and will destroy
everything and if that's the case then
why do any of these other things matter
on an individual basis if the whole
universe is at threat why do we need
individual highlights for all these
specific characters even trying to make
that the central pillar doesn't work
and I can't judge this as a narrative
because it's not it is an incomplete
narrative what I will grant is that I'm
not necessarily going to criticize it
for not having a clear beginning middle
and end because this is a pure setup
episode I don't necessarily think it
should have been nothing but setup but I
will grant that is what it is that is
what it's doing so I'm not even going to
criticize it for failing to deliver me
any kind of conclusion or answer any of
these questions I'm criticizing it for
asking way too many questions right at
the start
so I don't know which ones matter and
about half the questions I asked will
not get answers because they don't
matter but here as presented as it
starts you can't tell
this
this really does set the tone for the
whole thing it just it fails to build a
foundation I was gonna say it builds a
weak Foundation it doesn't build a
foundation
it erects all this stuff that should be
on a foundation but there is no
foundation for any of it it's just stuff
things happening now this now this now
this now this
but we don't know why in like oddly
there's a very specific episode in trial
of a Time Lord that did make me think of
this
and I'll get to that when I get to it
but
this is a really rough start
there's some interesting
character beats some moments
but the overall thing is just
overflowing there's too much
there is too much and a lot of it won't
matter until later some of it won't
matter at all and I understand why it's
this way again they didn't have time to
streamline the scripts once they knew
they were going to lose some episodes
but the end result is still the end
result I can know how we got here but
still think it's kind of a disaster
because it is
the Halloween apocalypse have you
re-watched it lately what'd you think
about this whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills allows me to do this as my living
these will be continuing on Wednesday
through the completion of flux I don't
know if I'll jump right into the
specials right after that I might have
to I don't know we'll see
um but in any case
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council and I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla Gourley and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]
thank you